tu aimes et un
email
e
tu es
rien
[Musique]
le mandat de m
et
je ne
dieu
m
[Musique]
jeudi
dans les montagnes sacrées de l'himalaya
bouddhiste rien ne peut surprendre rien
ne doit surprendre
sur ses terres où le moindre souffle de
vent devient la respiration d'un dieu
les merveilleux sont innombrables et
comme des pèlerins partis à la quête
d'un trésor on s'y promène ray presque
impunément
[Musique]
dans ce monde les apparences ne sont pas
plus réel que des visions les sons comme
surgies de l'espace font partie du
silence et histoires et légendes se
confondent
son
me
moment
tous
e
[Musique]
moi même en
le plus important pour moi c'est d'être
ici à modeler et de pouvoir offrir mes
post et en instaurant studio bones de
mieux connaître
les pratiques bouddhistes sont
semblables un morceau de sucre
on peut mordre dans le morceau ici là ou
de n'importe quel côté il est sucré
pour chaque individu il ya une pratique
qui correspond à aucune d'entre elles
n'a plus de valeur que les autres faire
un pèlerinage offrir des prosternations
méditer en retraite tous ces moyens sont
identiques
[Musique]
et
on n'est pas dans une vallée située au
coeur de l'himalaya la ville mythique de
katmandou autant plus dorée et au
fronton de bois sculpté s'étale de
manière tentaculaire englobant petit à
petit dans sa banlieue et sa pollution
visière et villages des alentours
pourtant l'un d'entre eux bonne date ce
qu'ils en aient palais signifie le
village du bouddha reste un petit
univers dont les aspects merveilleux se
mesure à la paix qui rayonne encore
c'est ici que se trouve le grand stupa
[Musique]
lorsque nous sommes venus ici pour la
première fois nous avons été étonnés
puis émerveillés par l'énergie qui
animait ce lieu
à quelles pratiques étranges charest ce
grand monument rond dans lequel personne
ne pouvait pénétrer et qui était vénéré
comme un dieu
alors nous sommes revenus encore et
encore il ya chaque tour de stupa chaque
nouvelle rencontre nous avons compris un
peu plus de la règle qui gouverne ce
lieu
[Musique]
notre famille est arrivée ici il ya
longtemps pour s'occuper du stoop à mon
grand père et son père et le père de son
père ils sont tous nés ici pour s'en
occuper
nous avons la grande fortune d'avoir
toujours été là nous sommes nés à bonal
nous vivons à bonne date et nous ouvrons
à bonne date
chaque jour dès l'instant où l'on se
lève le matin jusqu'au moment de se
coucher le soir on se mélange avec le
stupa on y pratique on tourne autour
depuis notre enfance
on tourne toujours autour du stoop pas
dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre
je ne connais pas en terme n'existe les
raisons pour lesquelles circulent
toujours de la gauche vers la droite
simplement parce qu'avant nous les gens
toujours tourné dans ce sens alors nous
aussi nous suivons la même tradition
[Musique]
dans ce monde où tout est mouvement on a
d'abord l'impression d'être le
spectateur d'une marche incessantes vers
on ne sait quel but une procession où
chacun constamment reviendrait à la même
place
cela évoque ce que les bouddhistes
appelle le samsara cet univers
circulaire dans lequel les êtres vivants
air sans fin
il passe ainsi d'un paradis aux enfers
et du règne animal au monde les hommes
soumis aux résultats des actions qu'ils
ont engagés dans leur vie passée une
fuite en avant l'existence en existence
jusqu'à ce que purifier de leur
ignorance il quitte cette ronde
incessante en atteignant l'éveil du
bouddha
[Musique]
sonam vient chaque matin se joindre aux
marcheurs puis il retombe bien vite
s'occuper de son hôtel le happy valley
c'est bénéfique de renaître dans un tel
endroit surtout pour la paix que cela
procure à l'esprit
c'est aussi un lieu propice au travail
on peut en trouver facilement sur on
peut tourner autour juste ou pas avoir
un lieu pour la pratique religieuse
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas d'endroits comme
ça pour se promener où pourrait-on aller
se promener juste comme ça dans les
montagnes et où aller il n'y a pas
d'endroits comme ici pour la pratique
religieuse on a besoin de statut et si
l'on veut des statuts ici il y en a
si on veut des déités il y a des déités
et si l'on veut simplement se promener
ici il y à un endroit parfait pour le
faire
les gens viennent de partout pour vivre
ici ils se construisent des maisons il y
en a tellement maintenant pourquoi les
gens viennent s'installer ici
pour pouvoir se promener autour du site
ou pas
l'ademe je suis ici depuis ma naissance
et toute ma vie j'ai de la dévotion pour
le stupa dès que je me lève le matin je
sens paix et quand je vois les yeux
juste ou pas qui ne regarde la paix
envahi mon esprit vraiment agréable de
ressentir ça
ici j'ai la charge du site ou pas j'ai
la responsabilité des cérémonies dans
l'année il y a quatre ou cinq fait pour
lesquels il faut faire des cérémonies je
m'occupe aussi de pouvoir aux besoins
des pèlerins il faut leur donner des
informations sur le stupa
et puis expliquer aux étrangers
[Musique]
d
oh la la
on trouve
il y à 2500 ans le bouddha chaque âme
une âme à enseigner aux hommes une voie
qui leur permettait de se libérer de la
souffrance
depuis cette époque ces enseignements
été transmis verbalement de maître à
disciple sans aucune interruption
d'abord en inde puis ensuite au tibet
[Musique]
gilani et le lama du stoop à son prieur
il le sert chaque jour du matin au soir
comme le veut la tradition il restera un
étudiant toute sa vie et devra lui aussi
parcourir pas à pas ce chemin qui mène à
la libération pour cela il suit les
enseignements d'un maître spirituel très
chic rinpoché qui lui-même les a reçus
de son propre maître
c'est de cette manière que la
transmission peut remonter jusqu'au bout
d'à
m
le monastère de cette chaîne est situé à
quelques centaines de mètres du grand
stupa aujourd'hui il accueille le début
d'un cycle d'études qui durera trois
mois
durant cette période des milliers de
moines lamaze et laïque recevront de
trichine coacher les enseignements du
bouddha
m
très chic une cote chaîne au tibet il
est l'un des enseignants les plus
érudits et respecté dans la tradition du
bouddhisme tibétain
héritiers spirituels de padmasambhava il
est aussi l'un des maîtres du dalaï lama
et
et alors
le
e
et
[Musique]
mais
qui est
[Musique]
en génère des bienfaits incroyable en
construisant des représentations du
corps de la parole et de l'esprit du
bouddha
mais ce qui symbolise précisément
l'esprit du bouddha c'est le stupa
on acquiert aussi des bienfaits immense
par le fait de tourner et
on obtient en particulier la possibilité
de se purifier de toutes ses
imperfections
d'augmenter son énergie positive
l'alluré de sa vie sa prospérité et
toutes les qualités ordinaire
un stupa contribuer de façon majeure à
la paix dans le monde il dissipe les
causes et les conditions qu'ils génèrent
des famines les guerres et conflits
[Musique]
et
la construction d'un stupa est soumise à
des règles extrêmement précise on ne
construit pas au hasard mais un point
précis de la terre pour symboliser la
paix on enterre dans son socle des
objets qui peuvent nuire au monde comme
des couteaux des fusils des cendre
au-dessus on installe des vases remplis
de fleurs de graines de fruits et de
miel cela pourrait générer ce que l'on a
pris à la terre ensuite en son centre on
dresse une poutre de cèdre qui va nous
sa base au sommet sa colonne vertébrale
et tout autour de cette poutre ont
rempli le stupa avec des textes sacrés
des figurines en terre qui représentait
forme du bouddha ou des miniatures du
tout pas
[Musique]
à son sommet on installe les reliques
d'un grand st tout cela pour but de
créer une sorte de corne d'abondance un
émetteur de paix
le stupa représente donc l'esprit du
bouddha
dans son interprétation la plus simple
la base du stoop à représente le trône
du bouddha et les quatre gradins
symbolise les quatre robes du moine
le gradin du bas et le tapis
le second la jupe monastique
le troisième le châle et pour le 4ème
gradins
il s'agit de la pièce des tofs supérieur
qui compte sans vie petit morceau cousue
le dôme du stoop à représente le bol de
mendiants et 13 nouveaux de la flèche
symbolise le bâton de pèlerin
lors de notre première visite ici ce
sont à socke et jim dunn qui ont en
charge l'apparence du stupa ils sont
parmi les seuls à pouvoir monter là haut
ils sont quatre comme leurs ancêtres et
comme ceux qui viendront après
alors pour quelques heures quelques
jours quelques années ils sont les
favoris des dieux barbouilleurs céleste
[Musique]
ce pour avoir filmé
voilà donc une
image
aux mondiaux à la pagode moins de volume
à bord
ne fermez pas
je m'appelle pattinson
nous sommes un groupe de fans qui
effectuant ce travail de nettoyage
bénévolement
nes ou pas ont été détruits ici au népal
6 to pas le stupa de johnny cash à
personne ne l'a jamais animé alors c'est
un lieu très important ce sera pas
vraiment très loin et de la dégénération
et nos grands parents et leurs
grands-parents il remonte aux premières
générations plus loin que ce que l'on
connaît avant même époque de nos
ancêtres
honte à vous
si le stupa n'était pas du toit y est
s'il devenait san c'est comme si on ne
l'avait pas le corps ne commencerait à
puis quand on ne se leurre pas ou
devient malsain pour le stupa c'est
pareil
[Musique]
on pour
et
vous
trois ou quatre fois par mois de riches
pèlerins font des offrandes pour que le
stupa soit rôle tant il donne de
l'argent mais participe aussi aux achats
de noël des comédies signalé de beurre
qui mélangée à la chaux servent à le
blanchir
on utilise du safran pour dessiner sur
son dôme les pétales du lotus symbole de
pureté
[Musique]
on dit que le stupa exauce toujours les
voeux de ce qu'il honore et que chacun
peut lui manifester ses espoirs secrets
à socke et jeunes eux aussi font des
souhaits pour leur avenir
peut-être encore un peu des souhaits
d'enfants
à souk lui voudrait devenir militaire
j'ai déjà essayé de me faire accepter
par l'armée mais je n'ai pas réussi vous
savez l'armée les militaires
j'ai souvent essayé mais cela n'a pas
marché
je vais continuer de tenter ma chance je
voudrais bien y arriver
[Musique]
est ce que je serais content si monfils
travailler ici oui je peux dire que j'en
serai très content parce que c'est ici
que je suis né c'est ici que j'ai grandi
et que mes parents mes ancêtres ont tous
vécu
je serais content s'ils travaillaient
abonnement
pourtant il ya toujours la possibilité
que mon fils ne suivent pas ce qu'ont
fait ces ancêtres je pense j'aimerais
bien une bonne chose qu'il devienne
quelqu'un d'important
un grand officier dans la police dans
l'armée ou un ingénieur ou un médecin
c'est vrai que supposons que je me marie
et que j'ai un fils
faisait son travail à bonne note
j'en serais content
je sais pas ce que je vais faire de ma
vie je prendrai ce que je trouve je
voudrais bien conduire un camion
tous les copains à peu près du tout
parle on allait à l'école ensemble et on
l'arrêté ensemble il ya neuf ans
je ne crois pas que c'était une bonne
idée
[Musique]
il existe un livre dans lequel on
raconte poster du stoop et les bienfaits
engendrés par le fait de tourner autour
de lui offrir de l'or de l'encens le son
d'une cloche du safran ou de l'eau tout
y est écrit avec une telle minutie que
si vous me demandiez de vaud lui l'air
même en trois jours je n'arriverai pas à
le finir
vous voulez je vous la raconte alors
voilà l'histoire du grand sapin est là
dans le temps j'essaie de terre
avant qu'il n'existe quoi que ce soit
ici
le bouddha de la compassion de l'asie
dont il ya une statue ici regardez ce
qu'il y avait à faire dans ce monde de
souffrance
tous les êtres à l'éveil ou l'état de
paix
[Musique]
visite alors qu'elle a jusqu aux enfers
pour voir combien d'êtres s'y trouvaient
et combien avaient besoin de gens
comptent adema milliards
innombrables
c'est quand
il en fut rempli de compassion et nos
larmes apparu dans chacun de ses yeux il
fit alors le souhait de libérer tous les
êtres de la souffrance et de cette larme
naquirent deux déesses pour na et à
tourner
une taxe pas pour na décida alors de
naître dans le monde des humains afin
d'y construire un grand stupa pour
pacifier la terre
[Musique]
devenu adulte à pour na se maria d'abord
un marchand de cochon ont elles eu un
fils après le décès de ce premier mari
elle prit un deuxième époux et ainsi de
suite un marchand de chevaux un marchand
de chiens et un marchand de poule
élu quatre fils avec ses quatre maris
successifs
du
a pour na qui avait été assez pauvre
dans sa jeunesse s'enrichit au fil des
années grâce aux activités commerciales
de ces quatre maris
et lorsque ses fils furent grands
elle avait été bien considérable alors
légué en héritage
après avoir beaucoup réfléchi sur
l'utilisation de toutes ces richesses
elle fut éclairé par son voeu est une
idée lui 20 oui je vais construire un
stupa
[Musique]
elle s'en alla donc voir le roi du népal
pour lui demander un terrain et la
permission de construire un grand scoop
a le droit lui donne à ce terrain ici
audemat et elle commença avec ses quatre
fils la construction du site ou pas
[Musique]
l habitacle
nous sommes en danger
[Musique]
sept ans
non
c'est un travail ininterrompu elle
réussit à monter le stupa jusqu'à 13
niveaux au dessus des yeux
au moment précis où il terminait le
dernier niveau une pluie de fleurs des
110 des cieux c'était le sénateur n'a
qu'elle n'a pu rejoindre
avant de mourir elle fit de souhaits et
des bénédictions pour des futurs de
chacun de ses quatre fils l'un était
destiné à devenir le roi tibétain qui
sont un des scènes l'autre d'adm à
sambava le maître n'est du lotus le
troisième un dab et le quatrième un
médecin
ce sont ces quatre personnes qui firent
du bouddhisme la religion du type et
[Musique]
non
tous
on
[Musique]
à la suite de leurs souhaits les frères
constructeur du stoop a repris
renaissance au viiie siècle de notre ère
chacun dans une région différente et
lointaine de l'himalaya mais grâce à la
force de leurs voeux ils se retrouvaient
à bojan au tibet dans un désert de sable
afin d'y construire un monastère qui
allait devenir un haut lieu de
pèlerinage
[Musique]
non
par ailleurs
[Musique]
les
familles effet le premier monastères
bouddhistes du tibet c'est sur le lieu
de sa naissance au nord du kosovo ainsi
que d'autres endroits très saine on y
mettiez à la construction
c'est la raison pour laquelle il a une
telle importance pour les tibétains du
monastère fut construit grâce aux souris
à la connexion de trois personnes celle
des actrices ont découvert du tibet j'ai
une jambe par athina un grand sage
indien et padmasambhava qin et han ou
diana dans le pakistan actuelle ce lieu
qui enseigna le bouddhisme tantrique oh
tiens donc la réunion de ces trois
personnes qui permit la construction du
monastère de cimiez
le nom de padmasambhava signifie celui
qui est né du lotus il est considéré
comme le deuxième bouddha de notre ère
aujourd'hui encore les pèlerins font des
milliers de kilomètres à travers tout
l'himalaya pour le vénéré et le prix y
est
on lui donna le nom de maître ni du
lotus car il apparut miraculeusement
sous l'apparence d'un enfant assis au
coeur d'un lotus au milieu d'un lac
temmos des vieux trois mois d'un thermos
de thé padmasambhava enseigner ici
l'histoire du stoop à lézat construction
de la connexion entre les bâtisseurs et
le monastère de samedi
cet enseignement a été transcrit dans
une écriture symbolique
[Musique]
non
moutier admet samba 20 à cacher certains
de ces enseignements dans des endroits
tels que des statuts
mêmes raisons dans le ciel cela afin
qu'il soit découvert et répandu dans le
monde ya une époque propice
au même moment padmasambhava demanda à
ses disciples de faire des prières pour
être ceux qui découvriraient et
révélerait ses enseignements dans le
fait qu
il y a donc une combinaison entre les
bénédictions de padmasambhava et les
voeux de ses disciples qui étaient
présents lorsqu'il a dissimulé le trésor
spirituel
et c'est ce qui leur permet de s'en
souvenir dans une ville me
c'est cela que l'on appelle un terme à
un trésor spirituel mais l'idée dit et
celui qui le redécouvre arterton
le support de ses trésors spirituels est
appelée choc celle ce sont des
parchemins jaune sur lequel les
disciples de padmasambhava ont transcrit
ses enseignements
[Musique]
pour cela ils ont utilisé une écriture
symbolique que l'on nomme écriture
d'aida qui nient ou des faits céleste et
qui constitue une sorte de clé mental
mais par sa bénédiction padmasambhava a
aussi déposé des trésors spirituels
directement dans l'esprit de ses
disciples
à voir
oh
danton
[Musique]
autour du groupe à la route magique est
incessants de jour comme de nuit créons
une chaîne ininterrompue d'offrandes et
de prière pour la paix de chacun et du
monde en général
[Musique]
je viens faire des offrandes lampes et
priait pour ma mère qui vient de mourir
je viens à 5 heures avant d'aller
travailler
je ne me sens pas bien je ne peux pas
venir offrir des langues chaque jour
[Musique]
après avoir été retrouvé par un terreau
tonnes au 16e siècle à sammier le terme
à du grand scoop affût transcrit en
tibétain sous la forme d'un livre
cj annie qui le conserve aujourd'hui à
bonne date
[Musique]
au tibet ils font toujours comme ça il
grave les textes sur des blocs en bois
tous les livres sont imprimés comme ça
[Musique]
ce texte de papa samba parle juste ou
pas
il dit qu'il a construit comment il a
été bâti et ce qu'ils signifiaient
il décrit les bienfaits qu'ils
engendrent les fruits que l'on peut
attendre des offrandes qu'on lui fait
comme les drapeaux de prière
tourner autour de lui faire tourner les
moulins à prières allumé des lampes à
beurre
tout est décrit dans ce livre
si rien apparemment ne modifie la ronde
qui ceinturent jour après jour les pieds
du grand stupa les soubresauts du monde
extérieur atteignent pourtant les êtres
qui vivent de retour à bonne date nous
découvrons que sonam le propriétaire du
happy valley s'est rasé la tête une
façon de rendre hommage à la famille
royale du népal dont l'assassinât un an
plus tôt a bouleversé tout un peuple
selon les enseignements du bouddhisme
les offrandes de sonam et ses voeux de
paix doivent apporter un contrepoids
indispensable à la violence des hommes
[Musique]
toi tu m'en voudra pas
autour du grand stupa chacun apporte à
sa manière une contribution à
l'équilibré du monde et ce n'est pas
l'apparence du geste qui compte mais
l'intention
même les pigeons qui les ventes ne sont
pas nourris par hasard et pour que l'air
agité par leurs milliers d' elle
disperse sur le monde des prières de
paix inscrite sur les drapeaux qui le
par
[Musique]
je
car dans ce monde rien ne se perd le
vent la terre le feu l'eau et l'espace
deviennent eux mêmes porteurs de la
bénédiction des prières c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a pris les drapeaux aux
couleurs des cinq éléments pour les
offrir au vent qui balaye le grand stupa
et qu'ils déposeront ensuite sur notre
terre la paire accueillis au passage
m'appelle miles
je ne fais pas grand chose j'ai une
vache dont je m'occupe je travaille ici
je suis venue pour la première fois à 12
ans et je commençais à 14 ans maintenant
j'ai 84 ans
je travaille ici depuis
soixante-dix
oui depuis 70 ans
nous sommes les jo chiche resta
depuis l'époque de mes ancêtres c'est
nous qui montons là oh oui depuis le
début depuis que le stoop a été
construit c'est nous qui mettons là haut
qui sait pourquoi
c'est écrit dans les documents
c'est toujours nous qui le feront et ont
le taux reste personne et d'autres à le
faire
depuis combien d'années depuis que mes
ancêtres sont là
alors
allez savoir depuis combien de temps
c'est là devient bien deux mille ans
alors le temps le temps
or à caution
[Musique]
à l'intérieur du stoop il ya dit on un
étang un étang de l'est
un homme a rabattu saônois depuis n'a
jusqu'ici
[Musique]
comme loi entrait dans le stupa l'a
suivi
ils ont été comme emportés dedans sont
restés là près de l'étang
il y est resté toute la journée jusqu'à
ce que le moment soit venu de ram un
loup
il a donc il est reparti
quand il est arrivé chez lui on lui a
dit
mais tu étais tu es parti pendant dix
ans
alors il a raconté qu'il était resté
toute la journée à jouer aux dés à
l'intérieur dit pas qu'il n'y était
resté qu'une journée et alors quoi
qu'est ce qu'il y a qu'est ce qui ne va
pas at il demandé
mais pour sa famille il est resté
pendant
resté pendant 12 ans à l'intérieur
[Musique]
je pense qu'il
sur le côté nord il existe effectivement
une petite fontaine
et tous les 12 ans l'année de l'oiseau
un jour il ya eu une grande pluie
de l'eau sortait de la fontaine et une
très jeune
j'ai pris mon parapluie je suis allé
voir
il y avait déjà de l'eau dedans
les vider le bassin s'est rempli d'eau
une autre fois il s'est encore remplies
j'ai alors mis la main de temps et un
cheval
j'ai été chercher le récipient je les
remplis avec cette eau
l'eau que j'avais gardé chez moi changer
de couleur elle était parfois rouge
parfois bleu au jaune changer de couleur
de jour en jour les garder chez moi
pendant plusieurs
jours tucci crimp au tce est venu et je
lui ai raconté ce qui s'était passé
je lui ai donné de cette eau il l'a
mélangé avec de la farine et il en a
fait des pilules de longue vie
puis
il est parfois
[Musique]
c'est ici que j'ai vu de l'eau sortir
pour la première fois
depuis j'ai entendu dire que deux ou
trois fois à des intervalles de 12 ans
elle était sortie à nouveau mais je ne
les ai pas vus moyens
tout n'est pas merveilleux dans le livre
du contrat le maître n'est du locus il
prédit aussi sa ruine une prédiction
dans les termes sont étrangement
d'actualité elle dit ceci alors que
l'univers avance vers la conflagration
final le poids de l'obscurité se fait
plus haut
il n'y aura aucun répit dans le
développement de l'égoïsme et ses
conditions amèneront la ruine du grand
stupa et corrompus et les égoïstes
seront des gouvernants des avares et de
grossier démagogues deviendront des
potentats locaux les écritures et les
images sacrées seront profanés et volé
des ivrognes prêcheur on la voit on
écoutera la vie de flag horn alors que
des escrocs se vante au long de leurs
pouvoirs psychiques les signes annonçant
ces temps se manifesteront par
l'apparition de nouvelles c'est
fantasque mode vestimentaire
[Musique]
autour du stoop à la pression de la
ville se fait de plus en plus forte des
sa violence il déborde souvent
aujourd'hui les souhaits des deux
barbouilleurs céleste se sont réalisées
jacques tène conduit un camion il est
aussi devenu le chef des peintres du
stoop à
quand un soc il est militaire
basso qui est content de ce qu'il fait
il travaille pour le pays mais en ce
moment c'est dangereux à cause des
problèmes guérilla maoïste
on ne peut pas trop en parler
les deux copains qui étaient partis avec
aso xoom hors de lui il a été à
l'hôpital avec un bal dans le monde
[Musique]
e
touquet
[Musique]
je
on n'entend parler que de mort et de
catastrophes c'est pareil pour lui
jamais personne ne parle de bonnes
nouvelles qui font plaisir aux gens
nous vivons une période difficile pour
le moment ça va encore mais plus tard
ça va devenir de plus en plus dur
c'est ce que le maître louis letu 7 il
avait déjà prédit ce qui se passerait de
type et
les choses changent et partout dans le
monde ça change aussi
quand le monde va mal c'est normal que
je m'inquiète
alors je fais des prières
il faut faire des prières pour se sentir
en paix
[Musique]
si le grand stupa reste encore un lieu
de paix autour de lui l'himalaya comme
le reste du monde est la proie de la
violence et de la guerre au népal la
guérilla entre les maoïstes et le
pouvoir déjà fait 5000 morts
depuis 50 ans les chinois tentent de
détruire la culture du tibet
après avoir fait mourir plus d'un
million de tibétains et détruit presque
tous les monastères
ils ont remplacé les drapeaux de prière
du potala l'ancien palais du dalaï lama
par de simples drapeaux de couleurs
flottant sur un musée
tourisme et dollar oblige
[Musique]
la résistance du dalaï lama de son
peuple procède de la même démarche que
celle des habitants d'ustou pas à tout
acte de paix on obtient un résultat de
paix c'est la loi bouddhiste celle de
l'interdépendance celle de la non
violence
le maître n'est ni lotus a effectivement
prédit la ruine du groupe à
c'était mon but
est le même qu'au tibet les monastères
et tout laisse ou pas ont été détruits
il viendra un jour où le stupa de bonnes
notes lui aussi disparu
tout est impermanent
rien ne dure éternellement
le stupa a déjà été abîmée restaurée de
nombreuses fois et à chaque fois il
s'est trouvé en plus grand et plus
[Musique]
ils sont en marche depuis très longtemps
une longue marche où chaque pas chaque
acte de paix les rapproche de l'éveil de
l'état de bouddha
ce soir pour que cette ps réponde sur le
monde ils ont allumé cent mille lampes
tables
[Musique]
et
e
je
[Musique]
e
je
[Musique]
oh
me
e
[Musique]
mon
m
[Musique]
et
le
[Musique]
e